في الاثناء تهمه قائد القوات الدعم السريه
محمد حمدان حمد تيم نسناهم فلول النظام
السابق بترويج شائعه مقتله واوضح احمدته
في تسجيل صوتي انه متواجد وسط جنوده في
مناطق بحري وام درمان والخرطوم وفي شرق
النيل وتوعدا بتقديم قائد الجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان لمحاكمه عاجله
ذلك الكريم الانقلابين شغالين بايات
وشغالين نشات هدام انا الان متجول داخل
القوات في بحر موجود يندرمان موجود في
الخرطوم موجود في شرق النيل موجود والان
هم مروج
لمقتل محمد حمدان فادي دعايات ودي كلها
اكاذيب بيدل على انه هم مغلوبين عشان كذا
هم الان يعني في دعايات دي انا الحمد لله
موجود داخل القوات ولا لو استشهدت افراد
قوات الدوله صف وجنود فابشروا بالخير ان
شاء الله الانتصار قادم وبنقول لبرهان ان
شاء الله يا برهان انت عاجلا ام اجلا ان
شاء الله هتكون في قبضتنا باذن الله